good morning Dwight how you feeling good
morning I great having a pretty good
morning headed to my dad's basketball
camp here in Atlanta are you teaching am
i teaching uh yeah I am um a lot of the
kids right now a lot of the kids and
parents are excited but I'm in Atlanta
so I'm doing a lot of smiling and taking
pictures right now then actually uh
doing the teaching I why are you so
emotional at the press conference when
the Hawks introduced you what what hit
you uh I think it was a just having a
flashbacks of training in the gym that
we had the press conference in and he
knows just a lot of different emotions i
say my family and all the people that
you know I grew up with I mean actually
just playing for my hometown team shows
there's a lot of different things I was
running through my mind you know but I
just saw the visions of me working out
it but right behind the gym that we had
the press conference in was the track
that I used every morning and then my
school was maybe two minutes away from
the gym that we had so I was just a
bunch of emotions when it be my mother
you also talked about confidence level
of maybe losing confidence and then
trying to get confidence back like that
it's such a strange thing to hear of
somebody who's as decorated as you at
age 30 but how did you lose your
confidence I just think you know been in
a situation where you know I wasn't
involved alive and what was going on you
know and sometimes as a player that can
affect you when you've been very
effective in NBA to go from that to
is basically you know sometimes
shouldn't like you wasn't worth too much
and you know I was just in a bad little
face but you know I'm out of it darling
you know I'm excited about was about to
have the next what was it tougher
situation the lakers are the Rockets uh
I wouldn't say it was just the situation
I was saying was it was just a couple
you know trials you know that you know
as as a human we all go through
different things and you know was
something that you know I had to go
through to make me stronger for for
today the situation in huge tonight I
just didn't understand what they told
you or how they were going to use you as
opposed to how you were eventually used
in the offense was was there a
difference in what they told you how
you're going to be used and how it oh
yeah oh yeah you know you know I was
being told a lot of different things and
you know it just didn't happen that way
but everything happens for a reason you
know I can't go back in the past and get
that time back so for myself I just have
to leave that behind me but it did
produce a lot of you know endurance you
know and patients on my part and I I
think it was good that it happened
because it really kind of gave me some
and I was safe gave me fire you know
just woke something up in me for the
next for the next years of my career but
are you going to be featured now in
Atlanta plan I don't think it's about me
being featured you know I just I don't
even want to you know think that you
know coming in this is my time to do
this and do that but I just want to be
able to come in and do whatever I have
to do to really help this team win and I
know that if I'm in tip-top shape I know
that if I if I'm coming and playing with
with total confidence in myself and in
my game
then you know our team will be great
it's Dwight Howard the hawk Center
joining a stand Patrick show Mark Cuban
said Kevin Durant going to golden state
is good for business for the NBA what do
you think oh you know I think he's right
you know because despite people know
being upset about what Kevin Durant did
it's handy knows not lawyer and all this
stuff every day meant the Golden State
Warriors is what a half the season is
going to be sold out every Kevin Durant
Jersey is going to be sold out you know
and they're going to get a lot of
attention so you know on a business side
of things no I think it is going to be
great for the NBA you got a favorite
memory of playing against Tim Duncan oh
yeah I actually grew a nice healthy with
a story all the time my first year in
the NBA you know Tim Duncan and Kevin
Garnett and over my favorite players you
know growing up and we were planned in
san antonio before the game I was
warming up and I was working on mine in
my team Ed bank shot and I thought I had
it down pack because I didn't miss any
of it before the game you know I was
playing against the coaches and I was
making all the bank sides I got in the
game and I saw to me and I said you know
what I'm going to try tenure shot on
Timmy I faced him up gave him a little
quick jab and tried to shoot off the
glass and he jumped I thought he's gonna
block it so I shot the ball as high as I
could and the ball it hit the top of the
backboard and the Bulldogs outside and I
was so nervous but he just looked at me
and gave me a mile and patted me on the
butt in it I like man I can't believe I
just did that without some not I'll
never forget how you changed numbers why
oh well I've had number eight number 12
you know my whole life and um you know I
just felt like you know I needed a
change
um I wanted something different I wanted
to come in with a different mentality
you know different me and you know the
number he has you know some a lot of
great meanings and the one that you know
really stood out was the new beginning a
new life and you know it was just so
I'll running that my birthday is
December 28 and you know I was I was
supposed to be Dan you know my mom lost
seven kids and all supposed to be the
eighth one and you know I ended up being
aged one that lives not all the ones who
passed away so um has had some
significance in my life your mom lost
seven seven children yes sir oh well you
talk to her about it I have you know and
uh when she first found out you know the
first thing she said was of course the
same thing that everybody said was you
know Kobe was number eight and you know
I was like okay I'm proud of you know I
think that's a very number if he warded
but you know what I was the first thing
she said with him once I explained to
her the meaning of it she was all good
that's cool he said she said she loved
it what college did you almost pick ah
that was tough UNC was my favorite at
the time so the party would have been
you at UNC I wanted to go to the school
where jordan went 2 and you know a lot
of the guys who were in my class that
year chose to go to UNC so I thought we
would have a really really good team
when you think of the one in done room
ah what I think know that these kids are
so gifted in childhood that they could
come out of high school and be pretty
effective in the NBA but also people not
good the business side of it you know 18
is not a lot you know about
finance and how do you know save money
and you know how to put them in stocks
and stuff like that and investing the
right things at 18 you know so I think
maybe going to college you know for a
year no I don't think it's bad you know
but I won't want to stop cheers from
living out their dreams because you
never know what could happen in a year
but those are the rules not abide by the
rules how injured were you with your
back and surgeries uh oh uh I know the
situation in LA I was supposed to sit
out for season but I really wanted to
come in and play I wanted to be
effective and when I thought that na was
blessed to have a situation to play with
the Lakers um so I just tried to do it I
could you see I think my first season
was pretty good in my last season you
know I had a couple of knickknacks here
and there but for the most part you know
I was I was healthy it was my decision
to sit down games or sit out back to
backs it was something that the team had
wanted um but on my hand I feel great
tougher to play with hardener Kobe ah
both of those guys are great competitors
I just think the time it was all you
know for all of us you know we were all
going different paths in our career
Colby was that the tail in on James is
you know on the rise so you know just
two different no type of teams but I
think that no time it is important like
I said and no clan with the Hulk's you
know is the right time for myself
because I'm in a no different space
physically mentally spiritually and you
know the Hawks you know three years ago
we're in a different position that they
are and now especially with the new
management
things like that no so I think it's just
a perfect time to be home oh that's a
veteran answer there come on answer it
who's tougher to play harden or hardener
Kobe who was a tougher teammate to play
with well I can't really say man I don't
want to stir up anything I think both of
those guys are great eclairs and you
know despite what people say no me and
Cody didn't have one of those bad
relationships like I said I just think
we were two different parts of our
career and I think a lot of things that
you know was going on I think it was
hyped up and made it and people thought
that it was mortis than what it really
was you know personally I could never
hate you know any player I hate on any
player you know all of us blessed to be
able to play in the NBA and it's not
easy to make it here it's not easy to
stay here you know so I'm never going to
hate or anybody else who made it no I'm
proud of all the guys who made it to the
NBA how about I entered for you Dwight I
say that Kobe's personality was tougher
to play with and James game was harder
to play with how about that I mean
everybody's gonna happen you can just
nod your head nobody will see it you can
just nod your head and I'll know that
you know it was the the correct answer
hey I'm putting you on the spot you're
good sport I wish you luck there in you
know kind of a second career here for
you going back home so have fun at the
camp and thanks for joining us if sir
thanks for having thank you the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience